are you tired of playing vanilla fallout  4 on your ps4 Bethesda wants you to have  mods as soon as possible I'm Tony and  this is your home brewed gamespot news  update the ps4 version of fallout 4 was  supposed to receive mod support back in  June but that didn't happen in a new  interview with Metro Bethesda's Pete  Hines was asked to explain this but he  declined simply saying the mob program  was under evaluation he added that he  wants to get mods on ps4 quote as fast  as humanly possible we're getting close  to a full year since fallout for his  release and ps4 owners would probably  like mods sooner rather than later mod  support for fallout 4 came to Xbox one  in May and of course it's been present  on PC since launch at this point we'll  just have to wait and see what the dez  de says keep an eye on gamespot for more  developments and for all the biggest  fallout news you're already in the right  place  you